hot breath that is something that is my
favorite
part about your comedy even uh beyond
the writing
which there there is a question about
thank goodness because i definitely want
to get into your writing but your
you referred to it a second ago as like
your comfort on stage and even beyond
that like
your timing and i know you have like a
jazz background like you play jazz piano
and all that and it's like
you're timing you're in zero
rush like your movements seem to be
just not choreographed but very
methodical like how
were you able to because young comics
especially
it's that nervous energy of i gotta get
these words out before everyone hates me
but like how were you and what was that
process of massaging out that anxiety
and
really just being like oh i have
all the time in the world up here
um yeah well that's a good point you
know i think the trap
is to feel rushed and the trap is to
feel uh like there can't be any silence
there can't be any dead air
um and i i used to fall into that trap
too of you know thinking that i had to
speak very quickly and be animated and
you know
my energy had to be like through the
roof
um you know and as you do stand up for
10 years
20 years you figure things out about
yourself and about your style uh
hopefully you're always learning you're
always dissecting
your own uh craft and the way you
approach it
um but but i kind of found over the
years that
you know maybe that was a little bit of
a crutch you know like to
to not give the audience any space um
and again it it depends stylistically on
how you work
for some people you know it's like a
machine gun it's like a sledgehammer
they go go and and i love it if you know
it's all about authenticity if that's
who you are
and that's the way you work then i love
it you know
but if it's forced and you're doing it
out of fear
um you know i would just encourage
people to explore
like what exactly are you afraid of for
me
i over time found that
you could find laughs or maybe even
extra little moments would pop up if i
allowed for a silence
you know because the crowd really reads
you
if you are like you said if you're at
peace
and unrushed and comfortable
then they're gonna go with you you know
they're always kind of
uh they're assessing are you comfortable
up there
they're assessing like what's this
person about and if they sense fear
or if they sense that you are um
uh you know just unsure
then the room will register that
but if you're really planted and firm
uh then i think they kind of lean in
and they want to know like where you're
going and different moments can happen
in those silences too
or maybe a look right like something
physical like a gesture
or you know a lot of things can happen
in the silences you know
so that's something i've learned over
time yeah one of my favorite quotes
we've had in doing these q as with
alonso bowden
said that if you're afraid to say it
they're afraid to hear it
i'm just like that's yeah it's a game
changer
yeah i mean i would piggyback on that
and say like
sometimes you're afraid to say things
but you know you have to
you know like so sometimes if i'm doing
a joke that maybe is like social
commentary
or something political uh like i'm a
little
not scared i wouldn't say scared is the
right word but i i'm just concerned
about making sure that it lands the way
that i intend you know
uh so i i think sometimes a little bit
and i'm sure
alonzo you know he he didn't mean it
you know uh i'm sure he's aware of this
too he he and i are great friends
uh but what i'm saying is at times when
you're afraid to say something or that
you're a little
like that that helps you grow uh like it
helps you grow
when uh you know because there's a
there's different types of labs there's
an easy laugh where you're just talking
about your family or
your girlfriend boyfriend whatever your
significant other
and then there's a laugh where you're
kind of stating an opinion or maybe
commenting on society so uh
there's different types of colors within
the course of your act so
so those types of things might require a
little bit more um
you know you have to be a little more
resolute uh in
i'm gonna plant my feed and i'm gonna
i'm gonna say this
you